[Music]
how excited are you to be kicking off
the grand chest toward 2019 well I'm
very excited it's the first leg of the
grand gesture my first time playing and
serious tournament here in Africa I'm
really excited and happy to be here of
course I'm very happy to be part of this
one of the biggest tournaments in the
world and to be playing against nine of
the best players including world
champion of course it's a very big
tournament for me and in my career and
I'm very happy to be given this
opportunity to be a part of this
tournament I think it's opportunity for
me and to play with such high level
tournament against Magnus a lot of
strong gems well first of all I'm very
happy to get back you know to this daily
routine here playing around cheese tour
after 2017 I missed one year so actually
I'm back here and to the you know little
bit new place for the grant is to hold
chess itself I was very happy to be one
of the strongest player I really want to
perform my best oh it's not wet enough
that I am playing here in all the
branches - I'm very happy to come back
this is my first experience in Abidjan
it will be very nice to try
new please yeah so the 2018 Grantchester
went really well for me winning was
obviously very nice
coming off the u.s. championship win
about a month ago now I'm just looking
forward to playing good chess but also
it's quite interesting because Magnus is
coming off a big streak so I haven't
played Magnus I don't think this is a
sink fold Cup last year in September so
just looking forward to playing against
Magnus more than anything I'm really
excited to be playing here and it's been
a long time since I played rabid and
blitz against the best in this format so
it's good to be back
you